amazon has announced that it's going to  start offering audiobooks for dogs this  is true I'm not making this up  Amazon launches audiobooks for dogs a  true story they're really doing that  well is dumb and we have footage of a  dog trying out  Amazon's audiobook service for the first  time earlier today check it out  a Tale of Two Cities by Charles Dickens  it was the best of times you are I knelt  down beside Marley his tail lay limp and  the life was slowly draining from his  eyes let's get this part then Marley  lived happily ever after in a big soft  meadow with an unlimited supply of  tennis balls a bad bad dog I'm very bad  doggy  maybe you should rub my nose in it I'm  such a bad dog  [Music]  you  you